so he goes to the private room gets
ready and then a girl comes in that's
young and then he's like wait a minute
and then
she basically starts being like like
just that kind of massage and again he
goes wait a minute
wait a minute
[Music]
Joe
please tell us how you feel about this
actually both Joe's oh dude I saw this
yeah both Joe's please wait where's the
thing at he's not saying anything touch
on me
going to jail
um going to jail
and they wonder why fish is having a
hard time make it to heaven
I stand for Jesus oh he got a massage
lady arrested hmm
the question is
did he come
that's always the question
apparently he stopped her like right
when she started to grab him or was it a
horrible hand job
and he couldn't come that's why that's
why I killed the cops that'd be more
reasonable his actual stories yeah so
this guy's like a boxer so he goes for
like you know he gets massages after his
like training and he went to the wrong
one did he ask for the happy ending
he didn't apparently so she was like
extra yeah or did he walk into a wrong
one and she thought that he wanted the
dick special I think that's what happens
that happened to one of my buddies he
walked into a place and then they
massaged him and then they started
reaching for his penis and he was like
whoa that's not what I was here for and
then he left so it's that but afterwards
he called the cops really which is a
little extra huh is that extra I think
so
um what if it was against the rules were
reversed I wouldn't do it but it's
against his morals I can see why he'd do
it because he's a he's a he's he's a
hardcore like Christian dude right and
he's like I can't violate I mean but why
couldn't you just like talk to the
establishment why did you have to make a
big that's what I'm seeing about and
then recording it and like telling
people yeah if you are a true Christian
I feel like you don't need to take it to
that extent yeah you know you can handle
it because also like you think that lady
woke up one day and said my dream is to
Jack dudes off and make money like she
ain't [__] doing this as a passionate
career that's the deeper part of the
news she's probably in really yeah like
who knows right like someone could be
holding her passport and she's stuck
here I thought she was gonna be I think
she has a passion for giving out her
hand drops in those Shady massage if
this was Amsterdam that's a different
question that's a whole different thing
right but like in these Shady like
backroom massage places it just screams
of like
kind of
yeah you know what I mean so like I
don't know let me tell you some of the
things people were saying that uh were
dividing the sides someone like a lot of
people were saying oh come on that lady
must make hundreds of dollars an hour
[Laughter]
God that gets like four hand jobs a day
they're robbing me
because like people were saying like
what you said they were like oh she
might be that's messed up that now she
has to go to jail she might have been
hiding from you know maybe she's not
supposed to even legally be here yeah
who knows what her situation is so now
that the cops have her it's like she her
whole life might be [__] but then
people were like oh please she's
probably Rich yeah that's weird huh
she's rich I wouldn't say it that's like
looking at a kid making Nikes in a
factory and going oh come on he's making
Jordans you know how much they are
Jordans are expensive bro that's a good
thing that is a good analogy right there
that was spot-on he's probably got all
the Jordans dude let's not [__] with the
like like the the the pimp he's probably
got the Travis Scott and he got an early
release
dude no that's a good point yeah they're
like it's the wrong person to really get
mad at yeah right and now she's got to
give the cop a hand job
also some people some people also don't
believe him they think that like because
like cloud chaser well they think that
um like most people kind of know that if
you go to a massage place at night
and it's one of those strip mall ones
I mean he really didn't know my buddy
accidentally went into one did he yeah
because did he call the cops after
and try to shame somebody on like
socially ah I don't think most people do
that no like why couldn't she call the
cops and not publicly shame yeah because
yeah exactly yeah yeah I think most guys
would just be like oh that was weird
like bro you know what just happened or
or they they just go oh no no thank you
and they start driving home and they're
like I think that lady was trying to
jerk me off I think that was 11 times
and then they go like maybe I should
have and they go you turn
or they check rub maps and they go oh
[__] that's on rough Maps yeah yeah my
friend had uh back problems and then he
was like
hilarious dude like I got back problems
so why did he flip over
so
he he went to physical therapist and you
got a massage he goes oh that was a
little better right and then he was at
work and he worked with the zad he was
in the warehouse and then he carried
some boxes and he's like [__] he's like
this is not working out and goes but
then it was like eight o'clock after
shift so he's looking for places and he
found one on his way home from work and
when he went there
um it was like those Chinese places
where they do it in the big room
so when he when he's when he saw when he
went inside he saw like like like the
like the whole common area where people
yeah where all of the things are yeah
and it's there's it's KOA it's normal
it's like a normal massage place right
so he has the front desk do you guys
have anything more private because he's
also kind of heavy so I think he gets
self-conscious and he just like I just
want like a private so he accidentally
said the code word that's what it was
and then he went to the locker to get
dressed and a guy showed up and they're
just like talking and and then the guy
pulls out like a
like a like a notebook with all these
like girls on it and he goes do you
think she's cute and he's all like yeah
she's pretty cute
just think he gets two guys just
shooting this in the shoes
yeah he's given all this he's given all
the signs
so he goes to the private room gets
ready and then a girl comes in that's
young and then he's like wait a minute
and then
she basically starts being like like
just that kind of massage and again he
goes wait a minute
wait a minute
she's like what kind of massage is that
right and then she just jacks him off oh
that's a real massage whoa right and
then he's all like
but it was nice yeah and then he
finished and he goes so can I still get
that back massage I'm still I'm still
sore and then she was like laughing
because she thinks it's a joke yeah good
job so he tipped her and then he had to
go to another massage place to get
another bag
oh wow and then the same thing happened
is this your friend MO again
no mitsu
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah yeah what a classic he's a dirty
little scoundrel I got it's basically
his name but a different version I was
dying so it's his friend he like
satello's bro I was like why I was like
why didn't you stop it and he goes it
felt too good
once the guy's going it's it's hard to
you know
I don't think honestly I don't think
I've ever seen this happen yeah I've
never seen a dude clout out he's a fun
he's a funny dude make content over I
think it's happening yeah I was looking
at his uh profile right after when I saw
all the news about this and then he was
getting tons of hate from everybody just
[__] on him just because they're
like you're not a real Christian like
this is [__] up what you doing it is
true what you said that wouldn't
technically be the Christian thing to do
the Christian thing to do is say no and
then just be like
yeah yeah like getting her in trouble
and then chamber yeah exactly in front
of the whole world like now and to like
make a funny video on Instagram that
doesn't seem like I stand for Jesus
moment no it definitely does not he's
like Get Away Jezebel but it's like
she's not even trying to corrupt him in
that sense well I mean there's such
specific stories in the Bible of how
Jesus treated yeah
is there a story where he goes and hangs
out with a hooker and then they just
talk all night about feelings and [__] I
don't know if it says they talk all
night and they pepper sprayed her right
after
whatever crater what he's a getaway
Jezebel
like what Joe said
that's what Joe said
you're gonna be crazy if Jesus did that
that would be so funny
I had like a symbolism no it's pepper
spray
they had that [__] back then
I wonder I wonder what the cops thinking
too he's like man I gotta [__] do my
job now and process this because like
obviously cops know these things exist
too and it's not like it's on their
[__] you know a gender duck we're
gonna stop this particular thing in this
city it's like you know they're like now
we gotta do this shitty job now we have
to do something about it you know that's
what makes it feel even weirder it's
like when you look at Figueroa right you
look at the blade like all day long it's
an ecosystem of street prostitutes and
police and they're just kind of it's
like a soft uh allowment they're like
okay if it's gonna happen at least let
it be as safe as possible yeah you know
it's like a weird thing where there's
like a they they do turn the other way
for these like massage places but then
you got like an overbearing citizen
who's like I'm gonna put this publicly
online too and it puts everybody in this
like you know situation messes with a
business that's for sure but that's the
thing is most of these places don't get
in trouble until the cops have to come
for something yeah so now I wonder
what's gonna happen next though like
what can the cops really do to even like
are they is the move action like to
actually arrest this lady might shut
down the business they did arrest her
but now they're probably gonna audit the
building and then honestly all that's
gonna happen is they'll get kicked out
and a new one will be put in its place
with a different owner on the sheet
that's it it's like a smog shop yeah
yeah
you know what's the name of this place
called it'll just have a different name
that's like bad English or something
happy Delight massage
foreign